d'un an, a aggravé la situation.
Notre envoyée spéciale
à Kandahar, Marie-Eve Bédard.
- Zulmaï était policier au sein
de l'Armée nationale afghane,
un travail dont il était fier.
Mais quand il a compris que
le gouvernement allait
s'effondrer, il l'a abandonné.
Sans revenu depuis, il s'est
installé dans ce camp de
déplacés avec sa famille.
Pour survivre, il s'est enfo
dans les dettes. Il doit 8500 $
à une famille qui exige
maintenant le remboursement.
"C'est leur droit", dit-il,
mais il n'a pas d'argent. Il va
donc offrir en mariage au fils
de 18 ans de ses créanciers,
sa cadette Habiba, sept ans.
"La famille dit que c'est mieux
qu'elle s'installe déjà chez eux
pour travailler, dit-il, au lieu
de ne rien faire chez moi.
Mais moi, je leur dis qu'elle
est trop petite pour
er."
Habiba s'accroche à la chemise
de son père. Il lui a dit ce qui
lui arrivait, sans pourtant
lui expliquer le détail
de ce que veut dire le mariage.
"Elle le sait et elle me dit
qu'elle ne veut pas y aller.
Elle est trop petite.
Vous voyez comme elle m'aime,
dit-il, mais je n'ai pas
le choix, je dois le faire."
La plupart des quelque
300 personnes qui vivent dans
ce camp de misère en plein
de Kandahar ont été déplacées
de la province de Badghis par
les combats des dernières années
et la pauvreté.
"On ne fait que voir la viepassa
rien ici. On ne vaut rien pour
les talibans, alors pourquoi
nous aideraient-ils?" Le mari
de Zar Bibi aussi, a emprunté
plusieurs milliers de dollars
à des parents éloignés,
une dette qu'il faut éponger.
Sa filleuit ans,
fera office de paiement.
"Puberté ou pas, dit sa mère,
elle n'a pas le choix. Je dois
leur donner, dit-elle, c'est
une obligation, il n'y a pas
d'alternative." Assise à ses
côtés, Rukia ne peut s'empêcher
de sourire. Elle ne se doute pas
une seconde de ce qui l'attend
et ne prête aucune attention
à la conversation des grands.
"Si je lui dis, elle ne
l'acceptera pas, mais quand ils
viendront pour ma fille, je leue
ou pas. À huit ans, c'est
impossible qu'elle en soit
heureuse." Le moment venu,
pte mentirpte mentirpte mentirp.
Elle lui dira qu'elle part vivre
chez un oncle qu'elle n'a jamais
rencontré. Ce qui lui arrivera
après ne sera plus de
son ressort, dit-elle.
Je ne sais pas comment elle
réagira là-bas. Bien sûr qu'elle
est trop jeune pour comprendre
sa situauis certaine,
dit Zar Bibi, qu'elle va pleurer
et ne pourra pas accepter
son sort."
ge minimal
légal pour le mariage en
Afghanistan, histoire, dit-on,
de ne pas interférer avec
ires familiales.
Pourtant, cela n'a pas empêché
les talibans de publier un
décret qui fixe le montant
maximal que l'on puisse paye
pour une jeune fille. Un peu
plus de 5000 $, voilà ce que
peut valoir une jeune promise,
selon le décret. Avant l'arrivée
au pouvoir des talibans, l'âge
minimal légal du mariage était
fixé à seize ans. 28 % des
femmes âgées de 18 à 49 ans
ont été mariées avant l'âgede 1t
publié par l'Unicef en 2018.
L'organisme s'inquiète d'une
augmentation marquée du fléaucen
demande à Abdul Rahman combien
d'enfants il a, il répond
spontanément : "sept".
"Sept garçons", dit-il.
Puis, il se ravise, il a aus
trois filles.
"Trois d'entre eux
sont des filles, d
et sept garçons. C'est
ma fille."
C'est S
qu'il désigne.
Quelques fois par semaine,
Salia se'école'école'école'école
religieuse pour filles, près
du campement. "Ce sont les
seules écoles ouvertes, dit sa
mère. Elle y apprend à réciter
le Coran, mais elle ne sait pas
le lire. Les matières de base
ne sont pas au programme."
Quand onlle
aimerait, Salia répond
timidement qu'elle voudrait
apprendre à écrire. Un rêve
tout aussi simple, inaccessible.
Son père l'a ven
le village d'où il s'est enfui,
criblé de dettes, lui aussi.
"Nous n'avons auc
pour notre fille, dit-il.
Le père et la mère sontmer, pasi
faudrait-il que ses parents
la donnent comme ça?Elle devElle
correct, mais ses parents
doivent de l'argent.
C'est impossible d
Il faut payer ces dettes."
À ses petites filles qui seront
femmes sans jamais vraiment
avoir été enfants, on ne doit
apparemment rien du tout.
Ici, Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Ka